we're taking calls via discord
davidpakman.com
discord is the place to go and the way
that you can talk to me let's go next to
angel from new york angel you're on the
air
angel from new york welcome you're on
the air
oh sorry about that i was muted
now you're unmuted
oh we're good
uh my question for you i mean i work for
a public sector trade union a fairly
powerful one at that uh
my question to you is uh why do so many
people
in these trade unions
um
i'm not talking about teachers or police
since it's fair white
fairly obvious where they fall
politically and why they do
but what do other people fire fighters
uh steel workers why do they seem to
lean to the right
not just on cultural issues but even
economic ones and what can the left do
about that because it seems
like an unwinnable battle
so i take issue with one aspect of what
you're saying i think you are 100
correct that a lot of the kind of
laborer trade union members have
absolutely moved to the right in terms
of how they vote over the last 20 years
and uh i think that the part where
you're wrong is
if you really sit down and talk to these
folks about economic issues there are
they're very clearly on the left the
problem is
that the cultural conservatism of some
of those unions
combined with people who just are busy
living their lives and aren't really
thinking through the economic issues and
the proposals of candidates
are just kind of saying yeah i i believe
i'm a republican but when you really
talk to them about economic issues the
things they tell you
line up with what democrats are mostly
proposing and not with republicans so
it's unfortunate because they're still
voting for republicans but i don't
actually think that they have moved to
the right economically i think they just
think they have and they're part of
these culturally conservative
environments and so they just go i'm a
republican i'm voting for republicans
but if you really sat them down you'd
see that they really aligned with
democrats on economic issues
yeah i suppose you're right i uh it's
more of a signaling thing like i you
know i've got family members i know
friends
these people
they'll work for a public sector trade
union
which even have reservations about
collective bargaining against the
taxpayer but uh you know like one guy
will have a like the gadsden flag don't
tread on me yep uh at the very least
they'll signal they'll signal issues
with high taxes or or gas prices so i do
think that if if you sat them down and
really tried to get at how they feel
about things they're definitely to the
left and then uh
i guess where i'm seeing it economically
is still it still could be grouped under
under
a cultural understanding of where they
land yeah i mean with a lot of these
folks if you say what do you see is
wrong with the economy
how would you fix it
you're going to get a discourse that
points to democrats not to republicans
the problem is they still
a lot of them still vote for republicans
and that's sad but when you really talk
to them you would see that they point
left
yeah so what do uh what do democrats do
about that i don't know that i mean it's
again it's a messaging failure i don't
know the answer if i knew the answer i'd
be a political political consultant but
i don't know it's just an area democrats
continue to fail on
um all right well
thanks for talking to me all right
appreciate the call yeah i wish i had
something a little more
i guess optimistic to say
um that's gonna do it uh that's gonna
thank you so much angel from uh from new
york appreciate it that's going to do it
for calls today i as always was unable
to get to every caller but i'm going to
try to get to more callers when we take
calls again we'll take a quick break and
be right back with more show
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video